hello everyone and welcome to the second
game of the Tata Steel 2018 tiebreaks
here onigiri has the white pieces and as
you've seen in my previous video since
Carlson won the first game Giri must win
this game in order for there to be an
Armageddon round if Giri doesn't win
this game if there's a draw or he loses
Carlsen wins the tata steel 2018 Chess
Championship but as you've already seen
in my previous video he wanted this just
to show you how he wanted entirely so
Giri has the white pieces and he went
for efore so okay an interesting choice
when you have to go for the win
obviously you play E 4 E 5 Knight to f3
knight c6 and the Bishop to c4 again a
very interesting choice playing this
against Carson as cousins theory and
this opening is I mean it's a world
class he the most of the games in the
World Chess Championship he played
against the Sergey Kerrigan were played
in this opening so so weird weird choice
by giri but okay Bishop to c5 and here
as always I'm hoping to see before the
Evans gambit but I never see it Giri
goes for c3 the main line of the Italian
game Knight to f6 D 3 d6 and Geary
castles we have a 6 making room for that
Bishop rook to e1 Bishop to e7 Bishop to
b3 and we have castles h3 by Carlsen h6
Knight B to d2 rook to e8 and 92 f1 from
here this night will go to g3 and then
maybe later to f5 after this night will
support it from h4 Bishop to e6 offering
a trade of bishops Gary the clients a
bishop to see to any trades are in
Carlson's favor as Carson has to draw
this game and it's it's a game over for
Geary
which is ironic forgive it to win the
champ this
Tata Steel Chess Championship he has to
win the game and he didn't win a lot of
games this tournament but now he has to
defeat Magnus Carlsen
d5 Queen to e2 cost
captures d kappa d captures on e4 d
captors on e4 and Queen to e7 Knight g3
ROK to d8 simply developing everything
in the night to h4 now Gary's preparing
to jump to to f5 and here Carlsen would
be would be happier if this bishop
instead of an a7 was on f8 at to help
out with the defense so he plays Queen
to f8 not allowing this Knights to come
to a 5 would an attack on the Queen
night H to f5 anyway and the knight to
e7 here across and wants to exchange
that night right to e3
now Gary is preparing the other night to
come to a 596 by Carson now Carson also
wants to bring his Knight to f4 we have
Knight G to f5 and Knight to f4 now
attacking IRA's Queen on e2 Queen to f3
and here it's also a very very critical
moment in the game here you have to play
g6 this is the best move but you have to
spend a lot of time calculating it which
isn't something you want to do in a boy
the game here g6 is the best move but
it's not all that easy to see why after
g6
you have this Knight to g4 move now if
pawn captures night tonight factors
knight on f6 for King the king and the
rook so first you have to capture the g4
Knight and Knight captures and after
Queen captures now this pawn is pinned
still you can't capture and after King
to h8 you have this Bishop captures f4d
captures on each captures on f4 and
Queen captures an f4 not sacrificing a
piece after you capture it pawn captures
you have to find this Bishop to e5 and
it's it's simply too much to calculate
to realize that you'll be fine in this
position you have to see that after f6
opening up this bishops diagonal you can
simply play something like c6 and after
any threat of checkmate
after Queen to g8 your position is
perfectly fine already you're
threatening checkmate
those bishops you have are amazing and
black is better here but such a move
would
a lot of time and it's a blitz game
Carlson doesn't want to give Geary any
any time pressure so c6 instead we have
Knight to g4 Knight captures pawn
captures and here
Carson plays g6 and Geary again decides
to sacrifice a piece so Bishop
characters pawn captures and he goes for
it Queen captures on at four Costin
accepts the piece G captures on f5 we
have G captures on f5 and here again you
can save the bishop for example you can
play a move like Bishop to c4 but again
it's a blitz game you don't wanna you
don't want to do this after something
like f6 king - h8 making room for the
Queen you get E 5 now those pawns are
very scary this Bishop is freed but as
you play Bishop to c4 now we have Bishop
to d3 forcing an exchange of the strong
light square Bishop Bishop captures rook
captures and you're up a piece that
Bishop on a7 is a very strong Bishop you
will probably be able to play this but
in a blitz game those pawns and an open
King and h8 are and that's something you
want to you want to go for when the
whole tournament is underlined so after
G captures on f5 Carlsen doesn't try and
escape with the bishop instead he plays
King Queen to g7 so it's you know a very
a very bold move and he didn't even take
that much time in deciding and giving
the giving the piece back so pawn
captures we have rook captures and now
you can see that there really wasn't
wasn't any need to actually save the
bishop as non-crossing has this
beautiful bishop on a7 his king is still
very safe there the queen is also very
very nice there on g7 moves like rook to
f6 are coming the pressure DF to pawn
and this was the move where Geary missed
his opportunity to push ePHI you have to
push e5 and release this bishop if if I
was played then it's definitely
definitely a preferred position for
white now if you go after this ePHI
phone simply rotate the
and you can't capture the pond if you
capture it simply rook captures and now
of course you don't want to capture with
the rook because of route to d8 if you
capture with the Queen now the H pawn is
hanging so it's a better position for
white instead Gary missed this
opportunity to push a five he played
rook a to d1 probably preparing e5 next
move but now after rub D to e8 doubling
up now it's now it's not so easy to push
to push e5 here a Giri played rook to e2
he has to defend from rook to f6 going
after that f2 pawn as both the rook and
Bishop would be attacking it and here
Carlsen immediately seizes his moment
and planed Queen to g5 offering a trade
of Queens and Geary has upon up but
would opposite called bishops I don't
think Carson would have any trouble
drawing this game by Queen to f3 giri
the clients but now comes the rock to f6
you have to move Queen to f4 now with a
triple attack on the f2 pawn rook to f1
defending and rook to d5 preventing all
hopes gear ahead of ever activating this
Bishop on c2 also moves like rook to g5
are coming and it's a it's a very it's a
very bad position for white especially
when you have to win the game and all of
your pieces are so passive Queen to h2
here Gary offers a trade of Queens but
now Carson is no longer interested in a
Queen trade if you place Queen to g5 we
have g3 and now Queen to g4 attacking
the rock on e2 rock moves and now comes
the rook to g5 this is what a terrible
threat of Queen captures and g3 simply
winning upon their since the F pawn is
pinned he v attacking the rook and it's
this if I've moved now is a terrible
blunder by Geary
Carlsen probably if you don't want to
waste any time he captured the pawn but
actually rook f3
simply wins the game for black as now
there is an even more greater threat of
rook captures on g3 the point is still
pinned and after this check simply
- h3 wins the game you have to prevent
this kingi - unpinning but now comes a
rope to h5 you either have to give up
the Queen or play Queen g1 and here
after rook to f4 there is no there is no
defense against Queen to h3 checkmate if
you if you move the pawn doesn't really
do anything we open up this bishops
attack to the Queen and that there are
no moves here for for white probably you
have to give up the Queen and you're
still gonna get checkmate it
but after E 5 cross and don't wanna
waste any time to just grab the pawn
rook Bishop to d1 attacking the Queen
Queen g5 and we have rope 2 D 3 rook to
f5 was played here and here again it's
very hard to find a move there's again a
triple attack on the f2 pawn Giri here
played Queen to h4 and here for the draw
as it's simply a bad position for white
there there's really no chance you're
gonna beat Magus Carson and in this
position with the white pieces Queen to
h4
I mean Carlsen can probably still even
win this game you can simply capture the
Queen and then grab another pawn and f2
but Carson decided to accept the draw as
a draw is enough for him to win the 2018
Tata Steel chess tournament so in this
position a draw was agreed and like I
said in the previous video Magnus
Carlsen won the 2018 Tata Steel chess
tournament so yeah that's the game you
know a funny game for Geary first the
decision of playing efore then the
decision of going for a line that
probably cost some place better than
anyone else in the world he prepared
this line for his World Chess
Championship match against Sarah
Kerrigan in 2016 so but I mean what are
you gonna do it's not like you have time
to prepare for this I would like to
thank one Sally roses
Rodney topper and Phil Gardiner for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
once again I do hope you enjoyed this
entire coverage of the 2018 Tata Steel
chess tournament
and now I will shift my attention to the
guilt or chess festival have to see if
Nakamura will win his fourth title there
so yeah that's the game I hope you
enjoyed everything as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you all for watching and I will see you
soon